Maya. I see everything that you are.
I always have
don’t be afraid.
You have so much pain in you that you you
so much rage
that you can't contain it.
You and I
are the same.
So who's the monster?
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my new marvel Echo trailer break down.
There's a whole bunch of daredevil kingpin
going on here.
So if anybody's looking for a really good
lawyer, he's coming really soon.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I'll be doing videos for all the episodes,
but one of the big differences
with this series is they're actually releasing
all the episodes at the same time.
There might only be five episodes instead of the
standard six for a couple of different reasons.
Marvel is kind of testing things out
with this series because they're releasing it
under a marvel Spotlight brand, which is meant to be
for their more grounded street level hero stories
like Daredevil, the Defenders characters.
It's kind of like the Marvel One-Shot Marvel special
presentation brand, but for TV series, not movies
the Marvel
Spotlight brand is actually right out of the comics
that they're borrowing the name,
the whole concept from the comics in the early 1970s
For those of you that wanted to do a new Ghost
Writer series or like a Ghost Rider
movie in the MCU, They actually use ghostwriter
in Fantastic Four as an example of this,
the producers on Echo said that basically,
like back in the 1970s,
you didn't need to read Fantastic Four, like watch
Fantastic Four to understand
Ghost writer spotlight back in the day.
So it kind of makes me feel like they're going to do
a new ghostwriter project at some point.
Under this Marvel Spotlight brand.
it's also meant to be Marvel's first rated
R-rated, mature, like rated M series that they're
doing under the new MCU banner, like all the Marvel
Netflix series were rated mature.
So it's more in that vein like this is actually
kind of what the trailer makes it feel
it feels a little bit more like
the classic Daredevil Netflix series in tone,
which I think people are way more excited about.
like the trailer footage is making it seem like
much more of a banger than the descriptions early on
made it seem like like a lot of people
early on weren't that hype
because the eco character
is kind of like a D-List characters.
So a lot of people are like,
Why are they doing an Echo series?
Why not like another big character, like a Thousand
Big a B-list characters that they haven't done yet?
Basically, they pitched
is sort of like another daredevil versus kingpin
kind of series,
but using another character to tell that story.
so obviously
that is like the biggest part of the series.
You're like, that's the big draw
is that Daredevil and Kingpin are coming back
in a really big way ahead of Daredevil.
Born again in the series is meant mentioned
directly set up daredevil born again
even though they just took the dared of a born again
series back to ground
and are completely reworked again using the Punisher
showrunner in a bunch of the Loki people.
That's right.
The Punisher showrunner is now running Daredevil
born again.
Do you not feel that much more hyped about Daredevil
Born Again episodes?
most of the trailer footage is kingpin in Echo.
But there's a little bit of daredevil footage
versus Echo.
This scene here
where you see Daredevil fighting someone.
He's wearing his new version of the classic
red suit.
That's right. He's wearing the red suit again.
Finally, it looks kind of like an evolution
of the daredevil Netflix red suit,
kind of the same way that he wore the red
and yellow suit during She-Hulk.
And that was meant to be an upgraded version of
the Netflix like it was based on the Netflix suit.
now he's finally in the classic red,
I think, daring Daredevil born again.
He's supposed to be wearing
a version of the back in black suit,
like he'll have multiple suits over the next couple
of series that he appears on also probably
going to get a new suit during Spider-Man four
because we're expecting him to show up during that.
But that's not happening till 2025
But if you couldn't tell Zoom and enhance
here, the fact that he's in the middle
of is with the echo character
that's her pigtails in the background that you see.
even though there isn't a lot of him
during the trailer,
the rumor is that during the series he's looking for
Jessica Jones and she'll appear during the Daredevil
Born Again series at some point.
But that was before
they actually completely reworked the series.
So I don't know
exactly how the story is going to work
because we know Punisher is still going to be
a big character during Daredevil Born Again.
maybe, maybe there'll be some loose
references to him during the Echo series,
but because the Echo series is going to be so quick,
I'm not expecting a ton of other defenders
characters during that.
Maybe some Foggy Nelson. Some Karen Page references.
mostly to help set up Daredevil born again.
When things pick up with that series end,
even though I didn't mention this earlier,
one of the other big things they're using this year
to test out is they're doing a simulcast on Hulu
because Disney just arranged
to buy the rest of Hulu, and I think they're going
to be folding that into Disney
Plus so that it's like one service eventually
kind of the way the Star brand has worked on Disney
plus internationally.
So like if you live outside the United States,
there's like a star part of Disney
Plus that has a bunch of mature content.
I think that's what they eventually plan
to do with Hulu,
but probably not until like next year
or maybe the year after at some point.
Like eventually they'll do that.
but just starting with the trailer footage
we're going to wait through shot by shot
talking about Easter eggs wtf moments.
Like I said, most of the trailer is kingpin
and echo their back story together.
Like how he met her for the first time and
how he became kind of like a surrogate uncle to her.
most of this
they kind of set up during the Hawkeye series.
Like you get a little bit of her backstory in.
Like the way she got involved with Kingpin
as a little girl was the same was in the comics.
The idea is her father worked for the tracksuit
Mafia and basically led them underneath Kingpin.
But eventually he had him killed
and then just told Echo that it was someone else
turning her slowly into his weapon,
that he would just send around
killing people when he needed
people killed, basically like an enforcer.
one of the big differences, though, from the comics,
they don't really get into this during
the trailer is her special powers.
So she does have some low level powers,
kind of like Daredevil has powers in the comics.
She's meant to be kind of like a street level hero
in the comics.
The reason why she's called Echo
is because she can echo or mimic
the movements of anyone else right after seeing them
kind of like the Bullseye character
without a lot of his accuracy abilities.
she can basically copy anybody's movements.
So initially in the comics, Kingpin
sends her against Daredevil,
blaming Daredevil or lying
to her, saying that Daredevil killed her father.
So she tries to take him out in revenge.
until she eventually learns
that Kingpin was lying to her.
Daredevil had nothing to do with it
then turns against
Kingpin in, winds up shooting him in the eye
like she did during the Hawkeye series.
So that's why we see him in the trailer
with the eyepatch over his eye.
A lot of people were confused about this, didn't
he died during Hawkeye?
No, he did not die at the end of Hawkeye.
He is back in meaner than ever,
But I love the way that they start the trailer here.
This is obviously meant to take place in the past,
when she was a little girl,
there were some flashbacks
that wound up being deleted.
Scenes during the Hawkeye series
where he takes her out for ice cream.
I think this is meant to be one of those events
where he's taking her out for ice cream
and picking her up.
it's not clear
if the voiceover from Kingpin is during present day
and they're just juxtaposing it
with scenes from their past together.
but he narrates the entire trailer
basically telling her
that he's taking a liking to her
because he senses himself in her.
like there's so much of me that I see in you.
Like, we share a lot of the same qualities.
so he's kind of doing his Emperor
Palpatine kind of thing, drawing her
to the dark side of the force, so to speak.
that's why they're using the tagline of the trailer.
It's like no bad deed goes unpunished.
The whole idea that she turns into more
of an anti-hero through the course of the series,
kind of like the Punisher type of character, only
he wasn't quite as overtly evil to begin with.
Working for the forces of darkness, so to speak.
but basically, this opening scene is him
watching an ice cream vendor,
like they mentioned, getting ice cream together,
making fun of her disability,
and he just loses it on him.
does this remind you of his classic car
takedown from the Daredevil Netflix series?
So hard core, just watching him absolutely lose it.
they also tune the color of these flashbacks to make
it look a little bit darker, like they bleed,
so to speak, the color out of the flashbacks
so that the blood stands out on his fist.
Notice he's also wearing the classic
comic book kingpin white suit,
also makes the color of his bloody face pop
a lot to the black shirt that he wears underneath.
That obviously meant to contrast the blackness
of his soul, kind of like a gilded person.
Like he walks around in broad daylight
under the mask of someone
who is good
but is secretly doing very, very bad things.
the the custom version of the Marvel Studios logo.
They also changed the Echo logo to it
looks a little bit more like the classic Defenders
logo from Netflix.
Do they jump back to present day
in the red light scene here actually seems like
it's from the Hawkeye series or at least seem
similar to the ones during the Hawkeye series
when she debuted.
she takes someone down at this gate ring
the make America's
gate again obviously a reference to make America
great again.
I think this is also a reference
to what's going on with Kingpin's larger
storyline in the MCU during this period
part of the idea is that Marvel Phase five is meant
to represent like a Dark Reign era from the comics.
all the villains sort of taking positions of power
in the United States, Kingpin was supposed
to enter the Daredevil Born Again series running
for mayor of New York City, and he was going to win.
so you think he's got this whole make New York City
great again kind of vibe posts snap in that's
happening during the Echoes series like he's running
for mayor or he's getting ready to run for mayor.
they reveal the January 10th premiere date.
Like I said, all episodes are going to be dropping.
There might only be five episodes to The grave
she's visiting is for her father.
Because this takes place
after the events of Hawkeye.
he'll probably be featured in flashbacks.
They make it seem like this
accident is the one that caused her to lose her leg.
these seem like more of the kingpin's thugs,
but not the tracksuit mafia.
These seems like they get more into her
Choctaw heritage.
She's part of the Choctaw Nation, and they're
getting into that mythology during the series.
And that's where her special powers
are going to come from.
so they actually did explain that
they changed the character a little from the comics.
She will have actual special powers, not just like
mimic abilities, like the classic Daredevil comics.
I think what they're doing is
they're giving her special powers,
using Native American magical tribal tattoos.
it'll be more like an iron fist kind of vibe.
But instead of kung fu, it's Choctaw
Indian mythology.
if you remember during the flashbacks in the Hawkeye
series,
when she was a little girl
and her father was telling her
that story about the powers of the special dragon,
I think he gets into that kind of stuff.
interesting connection
because a dragon is a big part of the iron fist
mythology
and also the Shanghai mythology too, notice
this scene of kingpin looking at this canvas here,
the painting looks very familiar.
Just like his debut during the Daredevil
Netflix series Rabbit in a Snowstorm.
This just seems like that
same gang that comes at that skate land
for maybe some of the people that she cares about.
Maybe she just comes to rescue them
and that's why she takes them down.
I'm not sure who she's playing.
But obviously the red light is meant to represent
the whole daredevil connections of it. All.
this seems like a flashback to Echo's birth.
this gets into more of the Native American
mythology, the series and her heritage.
I'm not sure what's going on with the black
and white flashbacks to these
might just be ancestors of hers.
these scenes are just like the flashbacks
with her father's stories during the Hawkeye series.
these might be more scenes with her father
when she was younger.
couple really big fight scenes that she has with
a bunch of other gang members in different places.
then when Kingpin starts saying to her
that you and I are the same, they start beating down
different villains in the same way, even though they
themselves are acting kind of like villains.
But I think the idea
that she's going to be more of an anti-hero,
so it's kind of juxtaposing their actions
like he's in the middle of wasting
someone that he's pissed off at
but the people she's wasting are way worse,
kind of more of like a Punisher type of vibe,
like doing bad things,
but doing them to even worse people.
this scene of him with the eyepatch
just looks like their reunion after
she tried to kill him during the Hawkeye series.
And it's
then sort of coming to terms with each other
like he's trying to justify his actions
in everything that he did.
The death of her father.
and she has found him
again, is about to try and kill him again,
permitted this time, Obviously we know he comes back
during Daredevil born again.
So there's no way this is going to stick.
She's not going to wind up killing him.
but overall, the footage does make
it seem really solid in like,
I think they just whittled the series down
to make it way tighter.
So there aren't as many episodes where just like,
nothing winds up happening
that might be one of the reasons
why they're dropping it all at once.
Just because they whittled the series way way down.
what will probably happen,
those that released a couple more trailers,
that'll give us more of the actual story
like this is kind of a teaser trailer,
just giving you some vibes from the series, like,
it feels kind of like the classic Marvel
Netflix series, like Daredevil, Netflix.
So I definitely feel like everybody is way
more hyped about the series
after actually seeing the footage, whereas before
everybody was kind of worried about what
it was going to look like, especially after Marvel
announced they were going to drop it all at once.
Like, Wait a minute, why would they do that
if the series wasn't fire whatever they wind up
releasing for the next couple of weeks,
Of course, I'll do videos.
The next big series after this will be X-Men 97.
I don't think that they're going to release
those episodes until they release the Echo episodes,
so it might be a little bit later in the year
before we get a trailer for X-Men 97.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
So of course I'll do videos for whatever
winds up being released. Right now
we're in the middle of Loki episodes,
finishing my Loki finale video
we'll post next week after they release it,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel.
So you don't miss that.
we also just started the Invincible Season
2 episodes
and it is
probably one of the best series of all time.
Not just best comic book series.
it is really bad ass by itself.
links for my Season 2
Episode 1 video down to the description below.
Everybody click here for my Loki Season
two Episode six Finale
Trailer video and click here
to learn about Marvel's new plans for doing Doctor
Doom in the movies and a lot of other big stuff
is going on behind the scenes
with the next couple of Avengers movies.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!